I'm not comfortable because you're young
you haven't watched my show you're
clearly not a fan but you know what
good luck to you buddy I hope it does
well Dean King called you you pissed him
off ergo you have no guest for Monday
and now I've got to go put out fires
with the greatest Superman our
generation has seen I've got faith in
you do on the show I know you'll do a
good job but let's just not let any more
of these slip through the through the
cracks okay okay so here's the deal ya
own own Benjamin Hett on Fridays when we
don't do the show that's because we
often go on location to either shoot
super videos or sketches and I was in
the car with Sven computer and I said as
a joke that he'd be hosting the show on
Monday I find out he's been texting not
gay Jared and johnny-boy a producer he's
living in his own personal hell he
thinks he's hosting the show I forgot to
tell him it was a joke so now we're just
gonna go with it
and see how he deals with the pressure
of I guess my job enter one Dean Cain
Peterson for me spend that he will be
his guest on Monday but Dean wants to
touch base for the big event hilarity
ensues
[Music]
actually spent it's not John it's Dean
Cain how are you buddy
can I run down some ground rules then
for how I go on the show okay Stephen
likes to do a lot of Superman jokes and
stuff and I honestly I played him but I
don't like that he does that and that
actually kind of pisses me off so if we
could stay away from the Superman stuff
that would be cool a lot of the younger
kids grew up watching the show did you
ever watch it in Germany do you ever see
it yeah you know a little bit about the
show then the Superman shows clerk okay
wait you watch wait I'm just gonna
clarify real quick
you what you watched nuts nut Stevens
show my show Lois like Superman oh you
did not watch that all right that's just
that's but it's actually the television
show it's a television show whatever
that's cool that's gonna jacked up
though cuz I'm like I prefer will you be
able to watch some of the show then
before I come on okay thank you but then
but don't but don't ask me about it no
series anything I don't want to talk
about it because there's just a and I
get it all the time okay no I'm sick of
it is what happened and then Stephen
doesn't he thinks it's funny and it just
pisses me off okay and also connect what
could I throw out one other thing like
hallmark movies and stuff I don't want
to talk about those either so no
hallmark all right good
perfect but I just want to make sure
he's clear I know I know some German
people and they're not funny
yes well you can ask me to have done I
wanna yeah yeah I'm gonna be awfully
uncomfortable don't you think you'd be
uncomfortable talking about Israel with
a German guy you know what happened with
Germany in the Jews right I didn't know
all this about you I'm not sure I can do
the show on Monday I'm gonna call Steven
and I'm gonna probably just kill it just
because I'm not comfortable cuz you're
young you haven't watched my show you're
clearly not a fan but you know what good
luck to you buddy I hope it does well
hey Sven I just got a call from Dean
Cain what happened what happened I was
you told if you didn't know who he was
oh it's the same thing when you do hold
you tell me you've loved his stuff I've
never heard Thomas sells books you used
it a nice guy I've never heard him that
man the German yes of course I mean
maybe he was drinking he gets that way
sometimes I don't know
set you up on the phone callers he told
you didn't came we're gonna call you
deem King called you you pissed him off
there we go you have no guests for
Monday and I've got to go put out fires
with the greatest Superman our
generation has seen I've got faith in
you do on the show I know you'll do a
good job but let's just not let any more
of these slip through the through the
cracks okay okay all right listen what
do you do if they say have you seen this
or have you read my book Oh perfect okay
thanks Ben see you later hey sir what's
up that was pretty much what I was going
to ask you
buzzer every okay well I mean the Dean
holding Kane situation that I can reach
no here's the thing I didn't I didn't
get a briefing right I didn't kiss his
ass
it is Dean thing that should be the
default I mean no entropy to be part the
kissing ass I mean it's it's helpful
just to assume that going with guests
obviously I'm doing so only in being
King Dean Cain's world I can't talk
about Israel
ten minutes later again angry phone call
from Stephen what the write them so that
happened right and then I like okay me
it just it just it just I think you're
gonna pull us together I've just really
I would focus as much as you can on the
the character even throughout the day I
just just recite the beat beeps and bops
cuz that's not gonna come naturally when
you're under pressure even right now
you were right now let's hear that let's
hear the beep beeps I'm you know pretty
good in the present world the only thing
that I'm not hearing the beep beeps
beep beep their only person I have to
talk to you today about this was Aaron
and obviously he didn't know anything
was going on so that's good people sleep
well
yeah you cute are you very much tomorrow
by the beats pitch meeting time as you
can see the room is just beaming with
energy and good vibes as spent computer
pitches his idea for show open
Jamie's sketch ideas in their pen
frenemies well that's going to be a
sketch of the top of the show that's
going to be me during the intro trying
to take off my helmet and then taking it
off and I'm like I don't don't get it
and if it works it's show time after a
weekend of sleepless nights and
strenuous prep time for Sven to rehearse
the opening monologue many of you are
still blissfully unaware out there or
inducing ppq with his world-class
trigger mechanism Stevens told me about
this before it just it's just smooth and
it just feels amazing it's just smoke
get really open great punch line just
like I know where he was reading my text
you know you're not doing the show today
right no and this was obvious since
yesterday
oh god panic you're panicking sending
everyone he thought bill was gonna fire
you
well he's on a telephone almost laughing
his ass off you know there was just very
very variable prank what's going on is
this what's happening is this him run
his weather and resume resignation he
quit I have a letter of spend quitting
because he he caught on that it was a
prank and he thought it was mean and he
sent me his ticket back to Germany but
then I looked I realized this is a
Photoshop because it says Monday April
10th so he was trying to double prank
here but this is a Photoshop so when he
comes back in and tell me he's a prank
we're gonna tell him he's fired anyway
and that's how you flip the script for
this this was a friend
I think you should I think you should
take flight no you have a ticket here so
I would just I would take the ticket you
kraut son of a [ __ ]
you missed the Photoshop on the picture
this would work if you didn't write a
date that doesn't exist so what do we
learned well when pricking a German be
prepared for a curveball you might pull
a fast one and turn in his fake
resignation or you might start a fourth
right no one knows it's never worth the
risk that's the point it's not worth the
risk
don't do it this is the point where I
would tell you to subscribe or hit the
notification bell up there because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot on
YouTube but if you've been signed up now
at lotto with credit com / mug club for
all the daily content to support us
there's probably there's not a pitch I
can make here that'll work so let me
just tell you this I have a cat in my
basement right now if you don't
subscribe at lotto with credit com / mug
club to support this content I am going
to kill him if you don't subscribe this
cat in my basement will die